papa cgv ce que tu vois ce que ça prend
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va faire les soldes quand même bon
c'est très bien aller à chantal ladesou
à bien son combat
chantal ladesou dirait la mère de kelly
sur la tête de ma mère mais c'est vrai
même c'est la roma qui lie ces tout
petits chez larousse elle est très belle
chantal chocolat la grande soeur elle a
converti sa vache au talent très bien
mais là c'est mon camion toi quand même
moins chiante à mourir on va jouer à qui
ce cache là dessous vous allez regarder
on a besoin d'une des jupes et à vous de
nous dire ce que vous avez vu pouvait
dire la vérité aux vampires
puis ce sera mon tour il regardait et
d'annoncer ce que j'ai vu attention
c'est exact alors qu'est ce qu'il
m'avait la la photo demandé ni jean marc
morandini moi j'ai dû rester longtemps
debout je vois un petit écureuil croque
une petite noisette
il y avait les petites pochettes
[Applaudissements]
faire peur alors là l'otan prévu cgv tu
vois ce que ça prend et tu sais ce que
tu vois a feinté un petit sapin
un petit sapin apprécié sapin avec
l'épave moi je vois je vous dis je vois
une merguez avec deux boulettes saba
c'est sympa lequel lourde attention la
troisième année du total je vois une
énorme
[Applaudissements]
égouttez fin du gag
je vous le dis on n'aura pas mieux
[Musique]